wir bleiben jetzt ein bisschen Spline
ich es gibt Menschen die glauben
ernsthaft daran das ist UFOs gibt und
Menschen die glauben dass Menschen die
an UFOs Glauben verrückt sind und dann
kommt plötzlich ein Professor der
berühmtesten Universität der Welt der
Harvard University zum bildinterview und
fordert eine ernsthafte Beschäftigung
mit dem Thema und da kommt man doch ins
Nachdenken wenn einem so die Tassen um
die Ohren fliegen
sie sind der beste Beweis dafür dass es
unbekannte Flugobjekte tatsächlich gibt
sie konnten nicht einmal von den
US-Streitkräften identifiziert werden
ganz offiziell spricht das Militär
deshalb von
unidentifizierten luftphänomenen
der einflussreiche aber auch oft
kritisierte Harvard Professor AVI Löb
möchte aufgrund der gefühlt immer
häufiger auftretenden UFO-Sichtungen und
unsere vorangeschrittenen irdischen
Technologie jetzt in die Offensive gehen
er fordert im Bild Interview eine
Zusammenarbeit von Militär und
Wissenschaft
ich glaube nicht dass das Militär die
wirklich besten Daten veröffentlichen
wird wenn wir wirklich den Ursprung
dieser Objekte erfahren wollen dann muss
es eine wissenschaftliche Untersuchung
geben denn in der Wissenschaft sind die
Daten frei aber
[Musik]
UFO-Sichtungen sollen beim Militär
tatsächlich ein stigmatisiert werden die
Piloten sind aufgefordert Sichtungen zu
melden AVI Löb glaubt aber nicht daran
dass sich das Militär wirklich in die
Karten gucken lässt
er will jetzt gezielt nach UFOs Ausschau
halten mit seinem galileo-projekt den
Himmel überwachen und die Daten von
künstliche Intelligenz auswerten lassen
die Ergebnisse sollen dann nach der Open
Source Idee jedem zugänglich sein ganz
ohne Geheimniskrämerei we have the first
sweet of
instrumentseinheit an Instrumenten die
wir in den nächsten Monaten testen
werden wir werden den Himmel ab Filmen
in Infrarot optisch und akustisch diese
Daten werden von künstlicher Intelligenz
analysiert diese Algorithmen suchen nach
Objekten natürlichen Ursprungs vögelnden
und unterscheiden diese von
menschengemachten Objekten wie
drohnenflugzeugen und Satelliten wir und
dann noch in irgendwas anderes ist und
alle verbessern im Prinzip
das Projekt setzt dabei also voll und
ganz auf KI Professor Löb glaubt sogar
dass der Erstkontakt zwischen
menschlicher und Außerirdischer KI
stattfinden wird
und als wäre das Projekt nicht schon
groß genug lüpfel auch noch den
interstellaren Asteroiden amour aus den
Tiefen des Meeres vor peruan Neuguinea
Bergen er könnte winzige Spuren eines
alien-objektes enthalten and so dissour
dieses Objekt ist ja ungefährlich es ist
härter als 99,7 Prozent der Asteroiden
die wir sehen es bewegt sich auch
schneller als 95% aller Objekte im
schwerkraftwerk der Sonne es können
prinzipiell unnatürlichen Ursprungs sein
ein Raumschiff und das herauszufinden
müssen wir die Fragmente des Objekts von
Meeresboden sammeln on the ocean floor
noch sind beide Projekte in der
Anfangsphase wenn sie aber erstmal
laufen dürfen wir uns sicher über viele
weitere UFO-Sichtungen wie diese freuen